welcome back to new rock stars marvel
head kevin feige confirmed that between
spider-man no way home and venom let
there be carnage
coordination occurred between these two
productions
with peter parker showing up in the
venom two post credits scene is it
official is eddie brock invited the no
way home cookout
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitched the wildest theories for the
dirty titles that we love i'm eric boss
and going broke with me today is someone
who's never late to the party jessica
clemens
i want to comment on something
on something it seems like jay wants to
comment on it first so i'm gonna let jay
comment on it let's introduce our friend
i mean comedian and host of the blurts
in the hood podcast jay washington no i
would comment on the same thing with
jessica but i think emt might want to
accommodate it or we're going to do it
collectively as a family
i have no idea what's going on our own
master of the nerdy arts crashing
multiverses everywhere mastertainment mt
what do you want to comment on
what is going on everybody and also what
is going on youtube what is what are you
cooking about
it looks like a cook
oh my god yes
i did i didn't notice i
uh this nerdy [ __ ] of spider-man and
venom are they gonna be friends are they
gonna be foes or is one of them gonna be
a no-show let's decide it right now
because kevin feige revealed in a red
carpet interview this week that there
was quote a lot of coordination between
the sony and marvel teams and the venom
team and the no way home team he said
quote we work together on it
which is exciting to hear because tom
holland has said that the stunts in no
way home will be more visceral with
increased hand-to-hand combat when i
hear visceral i think like inky
sludge uh venom right that's that's the
only thing that visceral can refer to
and uh tom hardy uh as of this taping
just posted an instagram photo of venom
eating spider-man and then quickly
deleted it that tells us something so
let's talk about the venom two post
credits scene we can talk about it
openly now that it's worldwide and what
this tells us about no way home because
eddie brock's reality suddenly warped
around him and it transported him to the
mcu promising some upcoming encounter
with spider-man will peter parker and
eddie brock be allies or will they be
enemies in no way home or will they not
meet at all yet what do you guys think i
think
they
so what i think is going to happen is
and fun fact i re-watched before this
your breakdown of the post-credit scene
voss just to make sure that my theory
might be correct so we
i i like the idea that venom has they
were like we're in this hive mind with
all of these other
venom or the other symbiotes so i like
the idea that there's a possibility that
this venom can be connected to the what
the symbiote that we saw in topher grace
and that he remembers this peter parker
and that's why he wants to attack this
peter parker either that theory or the
theory that he said in the movie that
he's like we have to attack uh we have
to be uh we have to be the attacker but
we have to detect like attack bad people
and all he wants to do is like find
someone that's worthy of fighting and
killing and i think who's more worthy of
that than seeing on this big monitor
this number one bad guy that's also a
superhero so i think he's really that
licking of the screen is him being like
i don't ever have a pass with this
person that i only know about because i
haven't disclosed that information to
eddie brock or that he's like this is
the number one person i can go against
but i do think already in the in the
movie they're not gonna be enemies i
think especially peter parker and venom
will be closer than brock and
um and peter parker i think it'll be a
cute little bit of peter parker being
amazed that an alien lives inside of a
human being and they can both like take
over each other's body and control it so
i think mcu-wise peter parker and him
will not be enemies i think eventually
they will uh team up together to destroy
whoever they're going against in the
movie um that's a different story i
think there's more than the center
statistics but i do think that
they're gonna be friends eventually
the beginning of the story though
they're gonna fight and that's what
we're gonna listen to so you think yummy
means what a yummy friend not a yummy
yeah i think i think there's something
that we
just because that scene of us not being
able to go deep into what this where
they started the symbiotes i think there
is something that we're missing and that
missing is the topher grace part and
that's what we're connecting to
interesting
okay okay
that's what i'm hoping at least
i know i think that she is right to some
degree but i do think that peter and
eddie are going to fight at some point
in no way home it's very i think it's
very much teased and implied at the end
of the uh in that in that post-credits
scene and i think that yeah like she
said it's because venom is watching the
news and j jonah jameson is just making
spider-man seem like the worst person
the worst villain this universe has ever
seen
and so venom and i really like how jess
brought up the whole hive mind of the
symbiotes because that's going to play a
big part in venom's future i believe
because and i think that
i don't i don't think that venom
remembers the events of the rainy spider
verse myself i don't think that he he
knows of that that happened but there
might be some type of like inclination
or like something in the back of his
hive mind it's like hmm peter parker's
are delicious and we bond very well
so i think that in over the course of no
way home that um venom and spider-man
will fight there will be a fight and
they will be at odds but at some point
eddie and peter will be like all right
we're gonna stop fighting and by the end
of this a piece of venom like a piece of
that symbiote will attach to peter and i
feel like he will have his own venom
journey um on his own and like we'll
have that traditional venom um peter
fighting with that symbiote suit with
his own little venom so i think there
might be two venoms at the end of this
is what i'm saying um but yeah that's me
that would be a really good way to
introduce like the spider-man venom zer
symbiote in this movie as being like you
can attach to this one and it'll be very
fun
yeah that would be very fun so like i
think that you know if if if peter
parker did get his own venom that venom
would eventually be killed because there
could only be one good question let's go
off this block like hey man we just we
just got you here we don't really need
you
thank you for your service
i uh
i think first and foremost i think i'm
finally glad that what i said three and
a half years ago had been confirmed by
andy serkis that tom holland basically
filmed scenes for the first venom and
they didn't use it
they didn't use it marvel was like it
didn't work remember venom is not the
same theme of the mcu so it didn't work
right but now that you're bringing
universes together the coordination
officially works i said this before we
started recording i think that at some
point yeah eddie and peter will meet
it'll be peter in his suit and venom
will jump out and want to jump on peter
he's going to jump on peter and when he
jumps back to eddie he'll have his
symbol because he doesn't have it yet
he'll have he'll finally get his little
symbol he'll get his version of it and
then he'll shoot webs because he's
picked that up real quick but i also
think what this means i don't think i
don't think they'll i don't think
they'll fight i think they'll fight a
little bit because naturally venom wants
to fight peter probably is just going to
fight in defense and he's gonna be like
what's going on and he'll take the you
know he'll make his headpiece go off and
then that's when eddie will open up half
his mouth and peter will freak out as
the kid does because anybody would you
see a dude with a half a sludge on his
face and then he closes back up and he's
gone and then maybe he'll talk for a
minute and venom will talk jump off and
jump back i love that idea that's how we
go wrong your show is called rogue
theory no don't you stop because i don't
like the way blossom
no boss is like things that make you go
first
no i think it's great like that is like
i that's the one thing i've been missing
from the uh the tom hardy venom movies
right is like that link to spider-man
he's supposed to jump on spider-man
first and that's why he whips around
it's weird to see him just kind of like
in a parkour across buildings it's like
why does a symbiote do this
like he should have been attached to a
web crawler before this this doesn't
make sense
so to just fix that i think that's all
so just fix that
i mean because that's the one big thing
we've been worried about we've been
worrying about venom we don't he don't
have that those two identifiable marks
i'm sorry mt he don't have the symbol he
has and he doesn't shoot webs those are
two identifiable things about venom oh
no i and i really do like what you said
about you know you know eventually we're
going to have peter parker in this venom
suit combined like in this venom
symbiote combined and i think a big way
that this could happen is
you know we saw in venom one how quickly
venom can heal injuries so maybe peter
parker in no way home gets really messed
up and venom's like let's go help that
guy and then he's and then he heals them
he's like oh my god this body is pretty
great he's like like he he bonds with
his biology and then like you said
he gets that
webby um
nature tom hardy's looking at him like
so what about me i mean
come back to me what the hell like
you're gonna leave me for the [ __ ] with
me together i had to cry i love you
i love your moment in no way no like i i
would love if venom just went back to
eddie just because he liked anne he's
like you know what i'll i'll miss anne
too much if i had
peter parker so i guess we'll stay
together
it seems like after venom two it seems
like such a horrible idea for venom and
spider-man to be combined because
they're both like teenagers and
themselves they're not like not by age
but like venom is just such like a
reckless like i don't know what's going
on clueless little oaf in the second one
that it's like to put that with peter
parker seems just like a recipe for
disaster you need that eddie brock like
straight man or
voice of reason character to be like you
guys stop
is it a voice of reason no is it a
really neurotic dude that's in the crowd
like he eats
a really tired man
jazz man that's just had enough
a tired man that's dealing with like two
kids yeah every eddie brock is just a
tour guide at this point he's a tour
guide to earth for this symbiote he's
like please don't eat the people this is
where you do this is what you do this is
what you don't do that's nice
take me to disneyland i want to go to
disneyland i want to get on a ride daddy
mickey mouse think about mickey mouse
don't go along and join me don't worry
about mickey mouse you just want to eat
mickey mouse that's why you want to go
hey i want to ask you guys what is like
the ratio of how much venom you can have
in a movie before it just becomes too
much then like i think that was the
issue with spider-man 3 in 2007 right
like you know uh sam raimi got all this
pressure by aviorade to put in venom in
the movie he's like i kind of just want
to do like you know i want to do a
sandman movie i i don't i don't need to
add venom to it but they're like but
everyone loves venom and i agree i love
venom but like if you do have i can you
just have one venom scene in order to
check that block do you need to have
more than one scene if you go beyond one
scene does that is it just too much
venom at that point he'll probably show
up at like one of the last battle scenes
because we'll probably forget that like
oh yeah i forget venom's supposed to be
in this um early maybe some of us will
i i don't think he needs to be on all of
it but it does seem like like you said
there they need to set up the like whole
null thing so it's like you kind of need
a little bit of more information maybe
they won't give it a no way home because
that's not his movie but
we need more we need we need more we
need more about venom to know more about
their origins i think that in no way
home the most that we should get and the
most that i'm expecting that we are
going to get is just like a
an initial fight between venom and peter
parker that misunderstanding like you're
a bad guy i want to eat you and then
they'll stop fighting and then maybe a
piece of venom attaches onto peter i
don't know but then just be like all
right i know you
i'm not involved in whatever what you're
doing so i'm gonna go
figure out why i'm in this universe go
do what you're gonna do and so like if
that's just like the more venom's in the
mcu
for the mcu fans that didn't go see
venom 2 sort of it's just like hey he's
here don't worry about it and then like
they're going to set up more and like
we're going to get into more of that
null stuff more of the symbiote history
stuff in either a subsequent you know
spider-man film whatever they're doing
with uh the new spider-man trilogy if
they are continuing with tom holland
after this or in you know obviously in a
venom three of scenario where
um who knows if he'll ever return back
to his native universe i mean i'm
assuming so considering how venom two
ended i think they're gonna come to us
i think eddie and venom are gonna go to
the cheesecake factory because it's it's
excellent in mcu i think venom has heard
the recommendation of a key lime slice
and he wants to look
the show is called roll theory okay i'm
gonna say some wild [ __ ]
yeah we love it it's sponsored by
cheesecake factory cheesecake factory
no listen to it we want some cheesecake
factory sponsorships are you crazy
we're on that train
right cheesecake is delicious but i do
have a question for all of you um what
are the chances that you think that this
universe that you know venom has gone
into at the end of the movie is an
amalgamation of the mcu and the sony
universe because after just just said
that they would smush the universes
together there is a chance that he's not
in the mcu proper like this could be a
smush universe of mcu and sony where
whereas the mcu that we know is still
like a neighbor universe yeah that's
simple i've heard you mentioned that
theory before mt i think it's
fascinating honestly that i uh quote me
if i'm or tell me if i'm wrong mt you
believe that all of no way home is not
taking place in the main mcu proper that
it's in exactly pocket reality yeah i
think that in the events of no way home
we're going to see variants like happy
hogan uh zendaya's character mj uh you
know all them die or bad things happen
to them and then peter's gonna be like
wow it's terrible that i'm spider-man i
don't want to go back to my real reality
where all my real friends and my
girlfriend are oh yeah i'm going to
stick here into this weird sony mcu
verse so he shows like ned's head in
that garbage disposal like you're not
real
you're not my guy in the chair someone
pitched to me too
someone was like so you're saying that
spider-man is in not his proper timeline
he's in a different one are you saying
that venom's in a different okay someone
was like what if he just jumped into
everybody else's timeline and he's
messing it up and i was like oh i never
thought about that um because we're
seeing this while doctor strange i don't
know i'm there's so many ties to this if
that's the key that would be very fun
but why would i i guess i'm just more
nervous about like why would venom be in
that same
i got a theory that loki
no way home and what if are all
happening at the same time and when all
of those events of the multiverse are
happening together that's what shatters
it like doctor strange's spell doesn't
break the multiverse by itself neither
does what happens with them killing he
who remains it doesn't break the
multiverse by itself but in or neither
does uh ultron whooping to watch his ass
from universe to universe break the
multiverse
but all three of them happen and
simultaneously will mess up the
multiverse so that's why peter will
probably be in different universes and
how you can bring venom in and then
potentially take venom out yeah i think
that's i mean you're right jay it's got
to be cracks in the dam right it's not
any one event it's there's a lot of
things that are contributing to this i i
totally agree uh mt to your point i i
think the whole idea of like a pocket
reality is fascinating it allows them to
go crazier with no way home if they want
to go in that direction they can wreck
everything i just wonder if like coming
out of that people might feel like well
then if it was all a dream did any of
this matter and the way that like that's
some people were worried
like nothing in west view really
mattered but that's why it was so cool
after west view all those residents were
like which
even if it's not a dream it's still kind
of like discounting the other ones i
guess the other properties from being
like
not just to say to mt's perspective of
like it might not be a dream but then
it'd be like did i have to watch the
other ones then um
which would be really sad i don't know i
honestly think that this could be like
sony's way of just taking spider-man out
of the mcu by making a new universe that
is a mcu a sony mashup and i think that
could explain why in the morbius trailer
we see you know of different version of
spider-man like it's just things to look
that universe just seems really weird a
weird amalgamation of the two universes
so i think that we could see
why
morbius looks like morbius
because michael keaton's vulture is in
is in morbius remember and that's steel
spiderman i think this is post
venom i think it's post um no way home
where all the universe those universes
mashed into one and so like you have a
variant of vulture that is a different
vulture from
our main universe it's very weird that's
an argument against the whole uh pocket
reality thing i mean here's the thing
the fact that this seems so based on one
more day there's a lot of you know
thinking out there that this is just
gonna be almost like a wizard of oz no
place like home just like was it all a
dream kind of wish fulfillment thing and
then by the end of it things are just
going to get turned back to normal but i
hope that's not the case and i think the
fact that michael keaton has shown up in
morbius which just feels like part of
sony's reality that sony at least wants
this kind of multiverse crossover to
feel more permanent and feels like it is
stretching more into the mcu and i i
think a lot of this is just like sony
doesn't know what they want so in the
meantime we're just gonna try to just
suggest that their universe is part of
the mcu as much as they legally can
right um
[Applause]
we're going to make our movies nice and
80 minutes long so you keep watching
them
craving the hunter craving
[Music]
you're craving some craving come on
that craving movie is going to slap i
feel aaron taylor johnson's going to
knock it out of the park yeah we won't
yeah he's hot
that's the only criteria you need for a
craving yeah
i got some i got some problems with it
let's go
um all right so uh just gonna reward
some points here uh jay i think you're
right by saying there's a lot of things
all these things are kind of taking
place at the same time and that's what
led to the the multiverse crisis that
we're in i think you were right on the
money there so you get a point uh
jessica you're gonna get a point for
this idea of uh i i think it's rogue i
think it's rogue this idea of the
symbiote connection with uh the topper
grace version uh i don't i don't know if
i buy it but i think it's rogue and if
it happens you're gonna get the rest of
these you're gonna
[Laughter]
uh and mt i love this idea of uh of no
way home taking place in a side universe
i i prefer it to be more permanent but i
think it's rogue i think that's a ballsy
idea and you certainly hit a point for
that kind of uh imaginative thinking and
i think it's really cool um so we're
gonna talk more about uh marvel's
upcoming schedule and why things got
pushed around this week um we've got
some more details since we asked talked
about this that i think we should
discuss but uh before we get to that a
quick reminder to check out all the
awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you can grab yourself a cool limited
edition shirt inspired by shanghi from
our merch partners at epic hero shop
they have some great shirts from other
merch inspired by venom 2 suicide squad
all the other properties we've been
living the past few months so find those
shirts of all the great merch options at
newarkstersmerch.com and some big news
from our favorite home security company
simply saved they just launched their
new wireless outdoor security camera
that's right simply safe the system that
us news and world report names
best home security system of 2021 it
just got even better this brand new
outdoor security camera is engineered
with all the advanced tech and security
features you want and need to help keep
you and your family safe we have a
simply safe security system here at our
super secret new rockstars headquarters
it's easy to set up and even more easy
to use the wireless outdoor security
camera has an ultra wide 140 degree
field of view so that you can keep watch
over your entire yard it is 1080p hd
resolution and an 8x zoom
that means you can zoom in and clearly
see things like the faces and license
plates to capture all that critical
evidence uh and hopefully they're just
passing by not
these easter eggs breaking into your
home to murder you but if they do
there's evidence for it now
this has a built-in spotlight with color
night vision so that you can keep an eye
on what's going on day and night it's
super simple to set up and it usually
just takes a couple minutes and it has
an easy to remove rechargeable battery
so it doesn't need an outlet it can go
anywhere on your property this camera
has it all and it integrates with your
simply safe home security system
extending its protection to the outside
together it means every door window and
room are protected and now your property
will be too to learn more about the
exciting new simply safe wireless
outdoor security camera visit
simplysafe.com rogue what's more simply
safe is celebrating this new camera by
offering 20 off your entire new system
and your first month of monitoring
service free when you enroll in
interactive monitoring again that's
simply safe.com rogue also we want to
thank upstart for sponsoring this video
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements you're not alone the weight
of debt can be crippling but upstart can
help you on your path to financial
freedom upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating that high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment with a clear payoff date rather
than looking at a credit score alone
upstart considers other factors like
your income your current employment
other credit history to find a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
in minutes for loans between one
thousand and fifty thousand dollars you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com rogue that's upstart.com
rogue don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
your income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com rogue and we
want to thank expressvpn for sponsoring
this episode do you ever read the fine
print that appears when you start
browsing incognito mode it says that
your activity might still be visible to
your employer or your school or your
internet service provider to really stop
the people from seeing the sites that
you visit you really need to do what i
do and use expressvpn think about all
the times you've used wi-fi at like a
coffee shop or a hotel or even at your
parent's house without expressvpn every
site you visit could be logged by the
admin of that network and it's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
my friends well here's the deal friends
your home internet provider can also see
and record your browsing data and in the
us they are legally allowed to sell that
data to advertisers and that's wrong
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private as it should be expressvpn works
on all of your devices and is super easy
to use and i love the simplicity it
literally just has one button that you
tap to connect so stop letting strangers
invade your online privacy protect
yourself at expressvpn.com rogue and use
the link
expressvpn.comrogue to get three extra
months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to learn more
uh so on monday disney announced a shift
in their 2022-2023
release schedule with multiverse of
madness shifting back six weeks from
march to may thor four from may to july
but black panther wakanda forever is
shifting a full four months back from
july to november and kevin feige brushed
this off as like production shifts but
marvel exec nate moore went into more
detail while talking about black panther
wakanda forever's production in atlanta
at the eternal's red carpet on monday
and he said that the delays quote give
us more time to get it right so it
sounds like black panther two may be the
reason behind the shifts obviously ryan
coogler has had to start from square one
to reconfigure the film after chadwick
boseman died uh but i'm wondering what
specific changes to the story do you
guys think coogler needs more time to
get right maybe there's so much probably
on top of chadwick's death you have to
explain the absence number one you can't
just go into
black panther two and everybody's like
where's the king and there's nothing
maybe you take what you know about dr
strange multiverse of madness no way
home and figure out how to apply those
multiverse crazy things that happen to
something in wakanda because again we
don't know if these will open up this
multiverse deal will open up the door
for mutants so you don't know if all of
a sudden now something shifts everything
and now
oh now neymar is here atlantis is under
is right next to wakanda by the ocean
and all these different things oh cool
yeah
to piggyback on jay's thing and this is
just also me thinking out loud on top of
that they have to yeah they have to
reconstruct a lot because chadwick's
gone but also uh i i think her name was
dorothy steele one of the tribe leaders
also passed away yeah so then there's
that and then there's still the
altercation of like what's going on on
set and then there's still the scholar
johansson in disney um situation that's
going on so i feel like that's part of
the stuff always resolved i think they
were financially like results
but i think it's to open the doors to
like other actors being like yeah i
don't want this going this way so it's
like i feel like that made a hiccup but
then also dorothy steele died which is
another hiccup and then they have the
stuff that was on set that's another
hiccup so there's so many things that i
think he has to go back in and research
and redo just to make it like better for
the audience and also still
give uh honest to the uh timeline that's
happening uh this is also me thinking
out loud and piggybacking on what jay
said because it's there's so much going
on on that set that yeah production had
to like stop now do we think it's going
back to the script i think that it could
be going back to the script because i
think primarily for me
it probably has to do with of leticia
wright and her whole situation
um and i think that maybe at the end of
wakanda forever kevin feige was
originally going to give the black
panther mantle to shuri but then you
know the actress was then doing her own
thing that is very much against what
disney is going for um with you know
their policies so i think that that
might be a different conversation maybe
they're shifting over to all right what
if we just bring in a killmonger variant
because i know that that was brought up
in the past in their past videos yeah
because
also if what if it still can and they
could still bring like exactly and
michael b jordan to be done boxing
this is true
he'll bring him crazy
the creed uh killmonger variant from the
iraqi universe
yeah there is a lot going on in that set
i don't know if whatever is going on
with leticia right would be enough to
like force them to delay your production
you know whatever's going on there it
sounds like there's more like bigger
story things and maybe some like
sensitivity things like they're they
need to add some more scenes to kind of
yeah maybe what jay was saying explain
what exactly happened i'll be interested
to see if the multiverse ties in at all
i think this is the perfect time to kind
of use the multiverse to just explain
this is going to be like a different
story that is happening under a
different context and a lot of things
about the world are going to have
shifted if we do go if we're we're
talking rogue not production based if
we're going rogue theory story based
there is still like i liked reading the
situation that happened with loki and
what if when people are talking about
the tva and they're like what if was
already done like when we were already
finished writing this series so i wonder
if that same situation is happening with
um black panther and they're like oh do
we need to now correlate with what if
because the tva is a big deal but not as
much as what was going on with black
panther in like in black panther and air
kill monger so it's ann shuri that was
so much of what if so they could be
going back in that story and being like
great if this stuff is canon at least
with shuri we have to make sure this
stuff is still tangible and can work in
our movie that's going to go forward in
the mcu so they could be going back and
giving her like more of like uh just
more
like not not giving her the black
panther mantle but she is like now like
a really big point of view
um and they could be redoing that to
help with what's going on with the
multiverse that'd be really fun or they
could be going to cast another small
black girl to replace the small black
girl that played sherry well yeah
let's talk about the new people their
cat because the michaela cole's in it oh
that's right winston c duke and her are
training and they post it on instagram
that they're training so heavily for the
role so it's like we also are just
getting a new character in general so
it's like making sure she can fit into
the story line is also really good and
we don't know what she's playing right i
assumed it was the one of the warriors
but it probably is not it's just because
she's such a good woman she's so strong
and she's bald and she's beautiful so i
just wanted her to be a warrior i'm so
excited for her she couldn't play
anything else she's like she's so cool
everybody remember everybody's first
things was like she's a royal monroe
she's a world she's storm and i was like
yo
just yet
like we ain't got it we didn't even got
a mutant line yet like y'all got to calm
down on this right
but again going back to how everything
plays out eternals the multiverse
changes all of this yeah they don't we
don't know what
they knew it they might have known all
this was gonna happen well of course
they do because feige tells them
everything but now it's like all right
we can pin her in to be this person we
just know she's this dope ass fighter
from a village we don't know nothing
about her so later on in the film what's
your name aurora monroe you know it
could be these different things
i i mean i it's probably not gonna
happen but i think it'd be really cool
for like
wakanda forever to be where um
killmonger infinity he like breaks out
of that prism from the end of what if
and
his vision of wakanda forever is some
like multiversal empire i i just i want
to see that at some point
that could be such a good post credit
scene that would be such a fun
post-credits scene and i'd be like yes
i would love to see it two-fold i can i
go with jessica i want to see i want to
see the animated version of killmonger
get kicked through something and then
all of a sudden the live-action version
is popping out like what is this like
all of a sudden now he looks at himself
weird because now he
sees himself in a different way that
would be fun to have pepper potts show
up in that too with sherry um i
the episode of what if was really fun
and i love the two team up and i just
love i love strong women i love strong
women trust me i do love strong women
you have strong women amen that's true
here's an interesting scenario that i
just thought of
be so like we know that you know there
are a bunch of kings out there kings are
coming yes the multiverse very soon but
we also have killmonger in the
multiverse equation now so like is there
a scenario where we see a war between
kangs and killmongers in the multiverse
like that would be crazy because like
killmonger is going to get as ambitious
too many cases of black people i'm okay
it's a world war ii
that we didn't think that would happen
because all black people
sorry i keep adding because i these
things are coming to my mind uh they're
coming up immediately but we still have
um falcon in the winter soldier and we
still have a bunch of exactly so i think
that that will have to play in too
there's so much new information that
poor ryan coogler has to work by now i
don't know
but bucky was told he can't come back
right
but jessica it wasn't bucky totally
it was he well for a little bit for a
little bit it was like just stay high
for a little bit while we were yeah you
might want to stay
stay back bro don't come up to the
career like my mom and daddy don't want
you at the house you know he's not you
know he's not who when does he follow
the rules except for right now yo bucky
just
bucky cannot deal with unseasoned food
for for that long background i'm out
we're talking about
about
bucky didn't have that good
it's that good [ __ ]
exactly so he's gonna be back and he
probably got a boo thing over there you
know you know you know what you go black
no no he's gonna end up with sam's
sister sam's sister and also mt shut up
hey what you going back you know what
that might have been okay look him and i
was out there him and i was in the
jungle in the dog and she she had him
crying and everything he felt that
chocolate love in the soul
[Music]
well uh i want to move on to rogue
questions because perhaps the biggest
story and it's a story i've been
reluctant to talk about because
i don't want to bring attention to it
but after the eternals premiere at
premiere i was at and everyone there
it's an understanding you don't spoil
big plot events and some freaking
bonehead from variety went and uh
basically after the social media embargo
went up he tweeted a big spoiler from
the movie i beg of you don't go looking
for this i'm sorry if you already said
well you're not going to say
i had it spoiled like a couple of
minutes before real quick paid off
and i saw mt's tweet yeah i saw empty's
tweet and i was like okay don't look at
any journalists yeah the problem is
and the only reason this is a news story
it is really one person it's not news
that was out there there was one [ __ ]
who went tweeted and now all these other
journalists are thinking that it's news
scoops aren't news news spoilers aren't
scoops you [ __ ] yeah uh anyway but
uh that's gonna inspire our road
question today uh i want you guys to
write in your heads the worst possible
spoiler tweet that variety would have
written about a past famous twist in
movie history as if it was
a news scoop so thank god all the
greatest twists in movie history it
could been mcu in the past or wherever
and write the the stupid tweet as if
this were the night of the early
screening that would have ruined it for
the world i mean you gotta go with the
biggest uh most shocking cameo of all
uh nick fury samuel jackson at the end
of iron man one
it's just like i feel like you just be
like oh iron man was a really great
movie was really surprised that nick
fury was uh was about to start the
avengers initiative with samuel jackson
breaking the dog samuel l jackson shows
up after the credits of iron man don't
go see the movie now because i just told
you i got mine i got mine it's because
of halloween right
major hashtag soccer spoiler jigsaw gets
his throat cut by what a saw
is that what happens
and then anyone in the comments saying i
haven't seen it yet you've had years
this is different you've done bad years
okay i haven't seen chick-fil-a movies
and i care
my mom won't let me spoiler alert
malcolm x gets shot in malcolm x
[Laughter]
oh god it's very true i'm trying to
think of movies that were like
the hardest thing is like what i hate
about spoilers are spoilers and movies
where you like
that like
like the sixth sense where it's like
once you know the spoiler you don't
really re-watch the movie yeah and you
can re-watch the movie but you already
know it but i don't know i think sixth
sense is an example of one like you can
watch that even knowing the spoiler and
it's just as good of a movie yeah to go
back and re-see like oh
like i didn't i miss these parts i i got
it i got another one you just did it you
just started the success yo go go
hashtag spoiler alert for unbreakable
samuel l jackson did it like that's it
like samuel l jackson does it all like
that's all i see like what are you doing
and you're like oh he started everything
like he's a villain villain like he
ain't got no good bones but he's blowing
up [ __ ] which nobody explained snappy
little jackson's bones are like old rice
crispy streets but yet he was able to
make all type of evil [ __ ] happen just
to look for one dude
this man is built wow like old pencil
sticks with a head of
a member of the whispers who didn't
retire but everybody was like oh this
whole dude on the game is [ __ ] what else
oh my god yo if you guys haven't watched
unbreakable please go watch it it's a
great film but yeah
like first of all samuel jackson needs a
montage of nothing but his screams and
hollows and movies because it's like
character working
like where'd you get the crack of your
voice but look this man plays an old
black man which is crippled that don't
get disability but got money his mama is
just like that's my baby and bruce
willis is sad that's the spoil of
unbringing it
now you don't have to see it ever again
i think oh really good sorry i was okay
i don't know how this one is the one
that came to mind but i think a really
good way for vanity or variety to spoil
a good movie is to be like
uh hit movie million dollar baby
featuring hillary swank don't get too
attached hilton and then put hashtag
million dollar baby more like million
dollar daddy
daddy million dollars
that is peak
oh
million dollar baby
doesn't map covet and i'm not saying
they can't or they can't but i'm just
saying
we shouldn't attach the two we have got
all the rails
you pitched two pretty good ones there
between saw three and uh and unbreakable
so you're gonna get the point there uh
but i still feel dirty uh having to
bring up the spoiler thing at all i'm so
sorry that this happened uh for anyone
who might have seen that but uh trust me
the film still is very worth watching
and i will say this whatever you may
have seen about the post-credits scene
there is still
what i thought was the coolest thing
about the post-credits scenes that no
one has talked about yet and i cannot
wait to talk about it after this movie
has come out good to me that wasn't even
the coolest thing about them there is a
cooler thing that is still out there i
promise you i promise you uh so anyway
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks to our guests jessica
clements jay washington and mt you can
support our channel by checking out all
of our merch including shirts inspired
by chung chi venom and suicide squad all
your favorite nerdy properties
congratulations to jay for winning this
episode of uh rogue theory but all of
our theories were great i i can't wait
to see all this uh come up in the movies
and someday uh again you can find off
all of merch and new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
on all social media platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
youtube thank you all for joining us see
you next time everybody bye
bye bye baby bye babies
[Music]
so
[Music]
you